you'll die from a dolphin that's when a
dolphin becomes more dangerous than a
shark you have metal in your body I
don't have metal in my body I got metal
around my neck though you feel me what
does the metal have to do with anything
cuz of the vibrations that's how they
like you know no I don't so I'm from the
Bahamas so we learn a lot about animals
in the water if you have metal in your
body it like messes with the dolphins
like vibration in their brain and stuff
and that's how they really communicate
they're going to attack you because of
that it's going to mess with the
vibration so they just going to think
like you're an enemy right off the
coming straight headbutt you